as a lot people know I'm exercise a
great partnership with NASA over the
years and they've actually taken the
same cameras we were using you know just
to shoot this film they've actually gone
up on the space missions and film real
footage in low-earth orbit so one of the
first things I want to do for research
was to view some original prints of the
films that they've made we did add a
screening a series of different movies
of hours and hours of this incredible
footage down at IMAX kept seeing the
same name on them on the film's which
was Sony buyers so you know Greg an IMAX
offered to put us in touch from we would
call Tony because we wanted to say how
much we appreciate our work and how much
Valley we thought yeah nice the first
one I remember would be the dream is
alive that's the first time we flew
cameras in space well that was the first
time that's an incredible is that I do
remember that very clearly the benefit
of being able to look at footage of the
reality of being in an earth orbit shot
with the cameras the on the format that
we were then gonna use if it's like
there's a bunch of IMAX for me to look
at and exactly how that wouldn't really
help this is due to I wanted to give him
total credit for founding the space unit
is Graham Ferguson who is the
co-inventor of IMAX and he was the
pioneer that really taught us he
developed a syllabus for teaching
astronauts and you know a lot of credit
goes to him I think too few people are
aware of the achievements that you guys
have made in terms of getting those
cameras up there in the space shuttle
the flight deck and the a flight deck is
an incredibly small space so you have
very limited places where you can put a
camera we just had to develop window
brackets that you could place a camera
on with Velcro and it would be there for
them to work with but basically it was
ingenuity and you you did replicate the
feeling of a small space that's that's
going to be accurate
I was just astonished and astounded by
interstellar but what I loved about it
was the human story and in our films
they're viewed as documentaries and I
know they've they've inspired people to
do things but we're not telling the side
of the story that you did which is
absolutely amazing which is really what
it is to be human in what we know of the
universe and what we don't everything
that we have which is family and our
relationships to one another it is all
tied up with what's going to happen when
when we move off the planet
I just thought that was absolutely
astonishing well thank you
you